[Music]
all right so today's question comes from
patricia in kentucky
she visits daveramsey.com to ask prior
to raising my kids i was an executive
assistant
i chose to be a stay-at-home mom for 20
years my kids are now
adults and i'd like to return to work
but i'm not qualified for an
administrative assistant position
according to the job postings i see
online my computer skills are lacking
even though i'm very comfortable using a
computer
a lot has changed in how business is
conducted in the last 20 years
can you offer some guidance on what i
could do for a job
i've thought of taking classes in excel
hubspot google suite as these are some
of the qualifications required
but this takes money and time do you
have any advice
yeah my first advice is to call the ken
coleman show patricia so i can
gotta find out what type of work you
really love to do but i think it's kind
of clear here john
even in this this question submitted via
daveramsey.com that
she'd like to go back into being an
administrative assistant but she
has had the classic thought oh gosh i've
been out of the workplace for 20 years
i'm irrelevant and time has passed me by
the thought that she needs to have is
what made me a great administrative
assistant 20 years ago
makes me a great administrative
assistant today what is that that is the
talent
of being detail-oriented a person who is
naturally organized and has the talent
to
organize and spin multiple plates which
by the way is a stay-at-home mom
even better you got even better and so
you're actually really really qualified
what she's looking at is well now there
are some new computer softwares out
there there are new
office suites of things you've got to
use and she's already answered her own
question because she simply says
hey i can take some classes online excel
helps write google suite
uh but this takes money and time well
guess what save up the money
it's not a lot of money we're talking
we're not talking about going back to
school
here it's not that much money and it
won't take as much time go ahead and
commit to this she is in stage two of my
seven stages to meaningful work and that
is
get qualified and so she's already
figured out what she needs to do
she's figured out how much it's going to
cost and then she's figured out how long
it's going to take her based on her
budget go ahead
and commit but in the meantime i would
look into the marketplace for maybe some
part-time jobs to get your toes back in
the water to wade back in the water
maybe in some roles that don't require
all these specific administrative
assistant qualifications
and just go help people or go help a
small business friend who just needs an
office manager you can do that with your
eyes closed you raised kids for crying
out loud you have been the ceo the ceo
the office manager of a family
you're qualified go ahead and get in and
that part-time job or maybe full-time
job is just
some type of administrative help will
give you the money you need to get all
those
fancy qualifications to get that big
time administrative
assistant job so there's my answer
here's a here's a secret that i'm being
vulnerable and
telling for the first time i like this
um when i got my second big time
job at a college my responsibilities
went from a few people and a few million
dollars
to a number of people and lots of
billions
of dollars and i'll never forget the
time i turned in a
performer on a word document to our
president
and he looked at me as though i had just
handed him a plate of moldy bread
and said enjoy yeah and he looked at it
and looked
like turned it over and i'll never
forget his face he's a good friend of
mine
he said what is this and i remember
thinking that's probably not what you're
looking for so i
got a college student that snuck into my
office at four o'clock on wednesdays
and taught me excel and it wasn't as
complicated as i thought that's right it
wasn't as fearful as i thought and the
kid was
about 15 years younger than me at the
time and he helped me pretty quick
and so even if you've got kids in
college that can help you begin to learn
some of these things
for me it was about swallowing my pride
and saying i've got there's something
i've got to know
and i got to go find somebody to help me
do it that's right she can get there and
so can you